matthieu delormeau on fait du sport tous
les jours c'est tous les jours qu'il va
la salle oui moi je fais que les muscles
ne fait pas les choses de coeur je sais
que ce qui se voit
adacore à battre est bien barça ne vois
pas en quoi ça vous avez raison michel a
déjà commencé à pédaler michel drucker
est avec nous matthieu delormeau si la
chance est très simple michel face à
mathieu vous allez devoir pédaler
pendant une minute et pas dans la
semoule
d'accord je me mette une minute trente
foulard ap un gros coup de mou salle
qu'est ce tu préfères c'est michel qui
décide ça dépend à quelle heure arrive
le samu mais vu tu préfères ses longues
minutes d à michel un régime a entraîné
un nom mais 30
mais je pense que c'est en fait plus
c'est long plus tu vas le battre à mon
avis non ah oui moi je oui oui une
tanche récemment par une i30 une minute
39 a le même âge intentions michel
beaucoup plus vieux que moi ouais c'est
ça mais une minute trente
alors une minute trente vous allez
pédaler tous les deux je suis un vélo
comme à la télé alors attention et ce
n'est pas ce qu'il faut voir c'est tout
de suite mais c'est bon que ça a pas
d'abus dans le kunar est a renchéri une
1812 allait devoir pédaler pendant une
minute et aura fait je roule pour
benjamin la voiture roule pour benjamin
sur le tueur a fait plaisir
alors faut tourner deux fois le grand
nom de m voilà tu peux en peut leur
mettre à bas merci attention attention
de pédaler plus michel attention tu
attends au tu te calmes vous allez
partir pour signé du 36 et matthieu
delormeau qui gagnait 2,6 et michel
drucker égale le billet pour benjamin
castaldi
attention 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faux
la salade tomate et rassemble sur toi
[Applaudissements]
là
les 13 ans
rémi tales
[Applaudissements]
nous avons bien joué
500 m
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
et reste au sol
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
broothaerts base à moteur
[Applaudissements]
exceptionnel mais patrick et ça n'était
pas bébé saurions matthew paix la
séquence pour moi c'est un peu mafieux
de l'amour qui rend corps perdu dans la
peau ni plus